also leute werden das hier jetzt nach
hinten losgeht ich wusste das nicht mehr
es ist jetzt extra oder so also ich habe
nachgefragt das ist alles legal auf der
wand wo die ganzen sachen stand und sie
sorgen video das das man sogar ins
flugzeug nehmen darf hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich hab mir gedacht passend zu
weihnachten kann man nochmal ein fast
ein weihnachts juli tragen
heute haben wir das ganze eigentlich
gewonnen zum hinsetzen und zwar habe ich
mich da in erster linie auf jeden fall
sehr darüber gefreut muss ich sagen
vielleicht zeige ich euch direkt mal die
nachricht und zwar hat die liebe jackie
mir vor zwei monaten geschrieben
hättest du lust dass ich dir ein anderes
paket aus holland schrickel mit
typischen dingen von hier dinge die
touristen kaufen die auch dinge die
legal aber an der grenze liegen zb lied
lollipop etc ich glaube das wäre mega
lustig ich komme nämlich aus holland
liebe grüße und ich hoffe du bekommst
deine sachen bald wieder ach so da nicht
nämlich meinen rucksack verloren und mit
ihr habe ich dann geschrieben und sie
hat sich dann noch mal gemeldet meinte
dass ihr das 8,3 sogar videos geschickt
als sie einkaufen war juri kummer
das sind ja alles produkte die noch
legal sind aber an der grenze liegen
also es sind jetzt keine produkte mit
das sind jetzt keine produkte wo halt
drohen drin so weise also glaube ich
zumindest dass illegale paket aus
holland
okay wir schauen wir jetzt einfach mal
rein ich meine sie hat ja gesagt dinge
die tour ist gut wenn man nicht
touristen in amsterdam als kaufmann als
jugendlicher eine massage richtig ich
habe schon ein bisschen reingeschaut
damit ich es orten kann weil ich noch
relativ viele pakete bekommen deswegen
aber dafür schrieben betrieben bevor wir
das
wir haben heute im hintergrund ein
bisschen platziert hier juli broken love
you wieder immer hinter der kamera ist
wohl auch unterschreiben kann ja nicht
mal vor die kamera
der ist ja diese und hat heute seinen
ersten richtigen song release mittels
und ja würde ich mal in die video
beschreibung packen ist body styling
können alle auf jeden fall mal drauf
gehen bis hin zu worten die ganze nacht
durchlaufen lassen dann wird das gut
gerankt wird ne richtig und noch
irgendwas sagen er wäre cool wenn ihr
auf jeden fall genau so wie damals
vielleicht komme ich dann noch einmal
vor die kamera auf jeden fall so jetzt
erstmal alles in grün
na ja klar dass wir schauen uns erst mal
aber an die jüngeren von euch das soll
jetzt natürlich hier nicht irgendwie
euch zum drogen nehmen animieren auch
das sind keine drogen aber kommt gar
nicht erst auf die idee wollte ich noch
mal sagen lieber alex viel spaß mit den
sachen die gibt es in jedem typischen
souvenirshop in amsterdam
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn das
video gut bei den zuschauern ankommt
sollte das der fall sein wäre es mir
geliebt werde ich das geld zurück
bekommen könnte
da es für uns im moment viel geld ist
dieses mehr auf der hut und angenehm
aber ich wollte dass du unbedingt das
video machst ich wünsche dir von herzen
alles erdenklich gute und viel erfolg
und gesundheit liebe grüße von uns drei
holländern jackie o und ja also wie
gesagt vielen dank dafür habe mich sehr
gefreut und auch wenn das video nicht
gut ankommen krisztina toth das geld
wieder es war keine frage und musste
auch überhaupt nicht unangenehm sein ich
meine ich bedanke mich herzlich dafür
dass du dir überhaupt die mühe gemacht
hast und mir das hier geschickt hat ich
habe sowieso gedacht dass ich vielleicht
mal so ein kleines postfach aufmachen
wenn mir leute halt sachen entstehen
können nicht einmal auspacken
ich packe einmal so viel aus nicht dass
das lieber genau zielen und jede woche
ein polyp vielleicht habe ich schon bei
diesem video und ein postfach in die
video beschreibung gepackt wo ihr wenn
ihr wollt gerne sachen hinschicken
können die ich dann so jede woche einmal
auspacken und macht jetzt wird
uns aber hier dem paket war erst mal
ganz nah an die küste oder die gibt es
auch in deutschland eine meinung dass
ich nicht immer ein aber die haben jetzt
nichts mit drogen zu tun oder sind das
ganz typische clicker nahrung dass ich
sehe schon kommen wir zeit geld ich
kenne die gärten freund von mir früheren
bruder freund danach schöne grüße immer
mit in der schule also aus dem grund hat
man es ja schon in der fünften klasse ab
und zu mal durchgezogen nein aber wenn
du gehst kaufst du dir aber ein stärker
als auch dank christ diese waffeln das
ist kiefer nahrung alex pettyfer paket
geschickt bekommen was soll ein tolles
team verwaltet allerdings ok und jetzt
sind hier geschenke eingepackt
[Applaus]
aber ich habe wirklich den geilsten job
man muss immer nur sachen ausgepackt und
gegen was sagen dass man hier mit
weitermachen cannabis kaugummi 0 also
leute wie gesagt an die jüngeren frank
damit nicht an wobei das ist was legales
glaube ich schon vor beginn des videos
wo alex aber seid vorsichtig mit sowas
ja wenn ich irgendwelche nebenwirkungen
aufweisen dann machen wir abbruch
das wäre ja auch ein bisschen dumm von
jackie wenn sie das machen würde also
dass er illegal so was dann nach
deutschland zu schicken das wäre dann
wie also das ist so ein drogenkurier
steht ja nicht aufpasste wirkstoffe drin
sind schmeckt nicht
doch ich will jetzt nicht gleich seinen
meist nicht ob du ja von high werden
kann einmal cannabis
das kann ich legal und cannabis
kaugummis legal wo real kenner des
trainers
ich würds legal diskutiert ja und ja bis
jetzt noch nichts wert wenn du bist also
ich glaube das sind halt so sachen die
so an der grenze liegen meist du kannst
ja auch dieses gras ohne thc aber da
steht keiner
hier ist natürlich auch ansprache darauf
geschrieben die man so nicht da sind da
ist ein deutscher begriff für
zwischendurch cannabis cola hat ich
glaub echt also ich kann man das
wirklich schlecht vorstellen ist das
seien strafbar aber nicht dass keine
ahnung ich weiß echt nicht ob es legal
ist oder nicht ist
drehen wir halt gerade in holland also
ich weiß noch wie cannabis riecht und
das liegt halt auch nicht wie cannabis
aber du kannst ja einmal probieren wie
das projekt das könnte vielleicht schon
auf jeden fall schmeckt das meer danach
als kaugummis als die kaugummis man
wirklich nur so nach tamims oder so naja
das video kommt allein ich meine
ich weiß auch dass sich ältere zuschauer
und wenn jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben
vorbildfunktion händlern stark aus den
arsch alkohol das thema alkohol ist
immer genau natürlich auch also dass
hier guck und hier steht cbd in used
weißt du das ist doch das zeug waren sie
halt legal ist dann kann ich das ja auch
probieren
meinst du das wegnetz welche fordern
welche nicht ob ich möchte alle gleich
mit cannabis und zeit aber um zb de also
ich denke mal kosten sparen
sorry für die späte störungen wir sind
dabei das video zu drehen
also wir selber interessante produkte
müsst ihr dann sicher dass die alle in
deutschland also dass das möglich ist
die halt aus also hier zu testen
praktisch sah ich dass cannabis tun ja
so meinte dass also wenn ein echtes
cannabis ist das glaube ich ein bisschen
schwierig oder naja küste hat sich ja
nicht mit meiner entscheidung alles im
rahmen zu sein den g data capture news
youtuber in deutschland pakt drogen aus
dass das riecht aber auch gar nicht nach
cannabis oder es wird aber ich habe auch
noch nie gesehen dass richtigen wieso
nach baumart schulde ich habe schon mit
gutem video titel
ich habe keine ahnung ob dieses video
legal ist ich warte erstmal auf ihre
antwort wir packen weiter aus dass hier
sieht mir nach jenen die nach schokolade
cannabis schokolade ppd rcd
also das ist da brauchen jetzt mehr
jeder hört hier sind auf jeden fall
diese cannabis-pflanzen drauf schmeckt
eigentlich wie ganz normale schokolade
chris märkte schon was wir müssen wir
erstmal ein bisschen platz machen
cannabis machen
von euphorie cannabis macht den habe
nämlich kannst du morgen mitlaufen will
ich habe wollen sondern sommerwetter
übermorgen so ein wettkampf da muss ich
wirklich wert sein
aber kommen wir diesem kevins sagte sie
hat angeregt coupé steht hat auch wieder
mit viel cannabis leafs und sie glaubt
dass auch nicht schicken werde thc drin
also das ist wahrscheinlich den einfach
mit cannabis kauf es gibt ja 1000
cannabispflanzen so also leute werden
das jetzt nach hinten losgeht ich wusste
dazu nicht mehr
es ist jetzt extra oder so aber noch mal
wirklich viel gelangt gehört weiß ich
wirklich sehr zu schätzen was wir alles
einzupacken
[Applaus]
das kennt man ja weiß spd versteht aber
60 milligramm cbd also auch das ist
jetzt nicht so ruhig wie dort könig da
kannst ein bisschen verschlafen heute
nicht weil das ist ja nicht das problem
in deutschland
sobald irgendjemand irgendwas mit alten
passiert oder so da gibt ja keinen aber
wenn dann irgendwann in einem halben
gramm dabei hat dann ist er auf schreibt
jetzt die drogenbeauftragte marlene
mortler oder dass ich mich auf alles weg
die sich wie alle das war ja ganz
schnell bei der aktion bekommen also ich
habe mit drogen keinen kontakt so aber
wenn er dann hat ja gar keinen sinn
gemacht was sie erzählt weil er die den
space cakes na ja cool dass ihr das
macht also ich habe nachgefragt das ist
alles legal auf der wand wo die ganzen
sachen standen sie ist auch ein video
das das man sogar ins flugzeug mitnehmen
darf und das sind auch keine geschäfte
die irgendwas mit tabak oder so was zu
tun haben
die anderen natürlich 1000 duft stäbchen
und so stehen gehabt
marianna riechen deswegen hatte ich an
die sachen nicht durch den zoll kommen
und habe auch gar nicht meine
absenderadresse draufgeschrieben da noch
ärger aber das ist alles total egal dass
nichts drin und da steht auch überall
hinten drauf dass kein dieses tlc keine
ahnung
okay aber mann mann mann mann kind auf
den begriff thc in holland wurden oder
die das paket also komplett kühn ok
alles klar so paar jahren wir uns
eigentlich auch schon gedacht und ich
war noch mal sicher gehen um
nachzufragen megatoll für die aufklärung
ich glaube vielleicht ist das auch nicht
fällig wenn die sprachnachricht auch im
video ist von dir sonst wirst du sagen
genau aber nochmal vielen dank hat echt
eine menge spaß gemacht also was jetzt
hat das gewusst wir haben wir haben
total hier ist noch nicht vergessen
[Applaus]
der richter war komisch bis mariechen
der richter wissen nach stinke fuß nach
zeitz das nicht lecker nicht so war das
ist einzig der braun ist deutlich besser
er leute trotzdem muss ich sagen ein
mega interessantes video es hat und was
mir spaß gemacht ich hoffe es hat euch
aufgefallen und ihr nehmt das nicht zu
engen das ist alles in deutschland legal
dieses diese cbd produkte deswegen wenn
ich da einen blöden kommentare lese
glock ich denke das war vielleicht ein
bisschen hat aber nicht den kanal wir
sind auf dem weg zu einer million und
wir sind uns am morgen um 19 uhr wieder
gibt's neues video
haut rein ins um alex w